welcome to this video a 15 minute game
and I'm playing at just insane yep so if
I'm going to say this is just insane I'm
not in any way I'm trying to say
anything bad about my opponents players
just the name so let's see what just
insane is doing I haven't decided yet
what to do if you play see form I took
his taking time this early hmm okay now
really we all move one buddy Andrew from
Michigan okay Bishop to a fourth after
some very long thing hmm yeah what to do
against the dead
yeah there's nowhere specific draw back
to playing Bishop a for healing tool
just thinking if I maybe can try
something to put him out of the comfort
zone quickly maybe see five or something
Bishop f4 is not particularly dangerous
but it has some some points of course
okay interesting just advances Wow ok
what is what is White's response to e6
it may be just 93 m possible
okay I'll just play a normal benoni ye
693 looked a bit uncomfortable to me I
don't really see how what what to do
after you 693 okay and I don't want to
spend so much time so just going for a
regular benoni when he has played Bishop
perform really early okay it's probably
not not too terrible the bishop on a
form
wow this is some nice time that he's
taking jack okay yeah that's very often
a good idea flick in this check to put
black's pieces into some sort of
disarray Bishop d7 why probably plays a
form and it's not clear what exactly i
have if i have benefited from that okay
97 is also possible and let's get to do
that after a four i have seen them I've
seen in IDM couple of years ago with the
book with a similar position with a
knight on f3 and step Bishop f4 played
after a form like it could take castles
998 c7 and play a 6 which was quite okay
for black maybe I can get this in okay
black white can of course also just
retreat the bishop instead of a for
capturing is not really making so much
sense so it's going for a for now yeah
the IDM as some described is to get in a
six i wonder if i should actually do it
now and only okay it's not there is no
that's not there's not much point to it
doing it now i can i can play them other
moves first like 98 c 7 and then a 6
nowhere no big deal
yeah okay was the idea anyway and I like
to be ahead on the clock just just once
it basically never happened so I'm okay
um kyon Bishop to age 6 mm yeah that's
not not really great i mean great for me
it's not very welcome sight I wonder
what up Knight e5 here can I they play
95 now that the night has no good
retreat square so night XD 5d take c5
now can he does not need to play Bishop
h6 of course let's do this wishful think
wishful thinking really it would be
quite ok to have 95 night XD five de
five Bishop age 696 would be quite nice
actually ok I'm going to go for the be
fired upon Queen B 697 Queen B 6 is
often a bit of a silly move because it
runs in 292 to c4 but now the queen is
on d to that's not possible
ah interesting hmm yeah well f6 is a
totally ugly maybe it is not that
terrible I mean what's my what are my
alternatives I can i can actually i
could consider to let him take it it's
not it's not completely out of the
picture 97 is what I'm talking about
that's actually a move at least Im I
don't see a big big drawback there
should be seven rook e8 and the bishop
move back side take back I take on b5
which is quite a quite a decent position
but I'm not sure about this night c7
Bishop e7 rook e8 9 a-4 Queen takes b5
Bishop takes the six that in fact looks
a bit strange but could be could be
quite okay why not why not for him okay
so hmm and what f6 is really ugly night
e to F 6 well I don't want to do that I
need 97 this was my IDM and putting this
knight on f6 years also looking a bit
strange
97 Bishop e7 rookie 894 queen bee 556 I
don't really have a move after that I
night is hanging on c7 in this position
unfortunately rook takes you for saying
that I could play in this position
Knight c3 c3 very ugly chest it's maybe
possible it's not completely idiotic
okay well let's let's just think briefly
about f6 how terrible is that f6 Bishop
to whom I don't know III may be 97 maybe
even before okay 97 probably at the end
I'm going to play this anyway right
yeah okay so Bishop takes 7 s is
essentially the only move that test this
if not if it does not take yeah then I
just play rupee eight and I'm fine I
don't this I don't see anything well I
always need to check night a form trying
to trap the queen but i don't i don't
see how after Queen B 5 is going to even
a Tekkit once more c4 I can just take i
don't i don't really see a point so we
should be seven i guess that's really
the only the only way to test this now I
didn't do it okay probably try to
prepare Bishop 92 okay I'll protect
yourself but I better keep this and see
what happens maybe I can consider to
take on c3 take b5 the greedy option
just grabbing a pond but it term it is
Sir it is dangerous of course yeah okay
yeah 94 of course I have 95 it's not the
end of the world anyway but I wonder if
um what the consequences are 95 white
must play Queenie to of course keeping a
b5 protected
so if i consider to take on 1c three
young not a move I like to play but
maybe I need two takes you probably will
take with the pawn that makes much more
sense to me at least take with the pawn
no I'd be five this loop be one very
ugly so queen bee five then probably see
form yeah well Mike Wiener does not have
any squares to be honest can go to be to
god it looks totally totally insane or
just insane just like the name here how
okay
the all-night c4s of course of threat
you cannot stuff to do ignore what if I
play it differently what if i play it
differently taking here on c3 when the
king is not such a big issue taking on
these c3b take C and then I'm then
trying to play for 4c form somehow
returning returning a pawn to get c5 and
make sure that i actually have some
squares I'm also still not quite sold on
Queen takes b5 not working c4 queen bee
to way it looks terribly risky but I'm
intending to go all the way back and c3
this 95 and Quincy to 2d three oh come
on I need to any chance at some point
this I was like a four-minute egg or so
ok so I was discarding Queen takes you
three all together I think probably
rightly so this just gives me a b5 okay
so Queen takes b5 here see for Queen B
to intending to okay Ruby one
you would get get to be seven huh this
is ok I can go to e5 so that is not
great ok I was also thinking about see
494 yeah 94th unfortunately just good
yeah Queen B 5 maybe Luke be 195 Luke b5
night XD 3 no it's also not great okay
if I play Knight e5 and then take on b5
with the Queen maybe and this at least
gives me a retreat square to d7 and
possibly Knight g4 ok ok I must I must
move and I must make a move and we use
in spending even more time
I can actually maybe well now now I can
even take on b5 with a night Ruby one
that's 93
maybe I for okay but I have this check
as well if I check him c4 check and then
night takes you three isn't as possible
night eggs now there is some Queen III
yeah which is not too great if I go back
the snide takes not not good as well so
can you to do this check and now taking
on on e3 I guess
yeah okay queena basically has to go to
you one I don't really see an
alternative mmmm no not really okay so
night hangs and I need to move it I have
no no technical trick so probably hear
night see for the screen d4 so I've won
how many points two pawns but it's still
very messy and I'm down to three minutes
am i okay he's just attacking it I go to
d4 don't like I don't want to want to
retreat it to some strange square he at
least I'm covering the night and he has
no direct discovery I don't see it so
don't see one at least
maybe I can get in Knight to f6
intending to take on leaf or even maybe
route 83 as a possible move iam yeah if
it's if he gives me some charter like
this what's this move doing maybe just
Queen over maybe I go Knight f6 this
Bishop e3 maybe he's really just
threatening Bishop Bishop Bishop to e3
and some some some way k b 5h three yeah
maybe
Jeff but ok it's not not the end of the
world maybe you can play age 39 f6
Bishop e3 25 Bishop f4 with a perpetual
attack on the Queen this is possible
maybe okay age 3 is the 95 yeah maybe
maybe 95 it's risky obviously but it
keeps the game going b5 is a useful move
as it protects c4 and possibly intends
to play before anchoring this night on
c3 yeah well I really expect him to play
h3 here maybe I'm maybe I'm wrong with
that but ok wyd can play a many moves
rook g3 I have this check on f2 which is
very necessary
yeah it's a very very tough position
with my queen stuck on d form its am
also very irritating peaceful white but
always a liability
it's taking some time okay so h3
probably still move that will have over
hub will be happening Knight f6 Bishop
is three Queenie five Bishop f4 and draw
not terrible but bit lame 8395 attacks
on f3 so Bishop e3 can be answered by
night xf3 and black wins hmm so 95
probably a roku Melissa in order route
g3 or something yeah and then Bishop e3
is the big thread yeah okay I don't want
to draw I mean I'm down on the clock and
everything but still a draw no oh wait
night wait I've got an idea rook g3 can
i play knight to e 2 which is a bit of a
[ __ ] move 92 that's it's quite cute
a1 is hanging and the rook is threatened
where's the rocco in chi gong nitey to
look III or something looks really weird
well what Rupe is free whatever playing
against rookies free maybe just going
back right
we should be three days 93 1 30 ok I
need to really speed up here
maybe I can actually play look III maybe
see three now let's could be playable
counter-attacking here nightby 3des
Queenie form okay so um I can take here
or here night see 494 looked III ok I'll
take the central stuffy at the central
pawns this should be ok and now would
like to get d5 of course time morning ok
let's protect you seven first
one minute
trying to get to d5 of course Knight b6
and takes it it's my idea okay I only
hope that I'm not blundering something
at the moment my queen only four is very
well placed to defending e7 defending
defending g6 rook takes this Knight c3
that look so came I don't he does not
have a child or resign oh that was nice
with 50 seconds left I think I think the
position is reasonably am um yeah
reasonably easy to play so I'm probably
won't screw up it wont to sweat up he
needs to play Queen he and I can just
just take it and that's a king of seven
keep everything protected the Queen if i
put the Queen let's say on e6 I'm
totally safe here rook c8 looks you are
looking for and it's pretty yeah it's
pretty pretty pretty safe what's nice
about the 15-minute games people are
rarely this well the you have got more
sometimes the position is a bit more
more friendly let's say we've got some
jets afterwards and some brief from
analysis term yeah he's pulling out
those moves I'm around here the position
is very tricky computer seems to be a
rookie h3 this is very good for why a
queen Queen to h3 this is what we played
okay Queen h3s given as excellent by the
computer yeah that's a strong move it
it controlled what's this important d 7
square and I have a bit of a problem now
hmm nyah it was a very difficult
position if I take here this rook be one
and I'm terribly pinned c4 is a huge
threat and something like that it's not
helping so I cannot do that if I take
with this there is a form hmm Joe yeah
that's very strong so this means that
Bishop takes you three is probably bogus
I was also briefly considering this
smooth but the problem is that after
something like that he'll just got get
to it be seven and i am not i'm not in
good shape this is why i try this knife
but Queen 83 probably we both missed I
didn't think of it as well and I really
have a problem with let's say I can do I
can do something like that to get the
night back but this is just the same as
before and if i go here it's also very
very terrible just just not great I mean
maybe this is it's just it's just
rubbish I mean it's not so easy to break
down but it's still very bad ok so this
bishops III probably is a bad idea then
and maybe my position is tricky already
now that's also it seems that I maybe
maybe I should consider to play a six at
some stage cook up playing age 6 yeah
I'm okay this is it is difficult to play
probably probably why does some is
somewhat better in any case yeah just
writing it into him that white is better
anyway yeah it's it's tricky improbably
I need to improve somehow maybe Queen B
6 is really not the right right way to
go i don't i don't know okay here the
computer suggests to take and then night
back to f6 wow maybe
yeah but still why do I dis also better
here this is also better for white this
is may be playable but well not great
yeah well the Benoni ax is a demanding
opening on it's one of those borderline
openings where you really know what
you're doing and well i'm not really a
benoni player i'm just experimenting
here getting some variety in in the
games but i'm not really am any sort of
expert on this yeah yeah after that I'm
okay probably check this seems to be
technically fine quindi force maybe whom
may be a bit bit bit risky be five but
I'm finding the finding the computer
moves basically here the comp wants to
play night a for I went with this which
looked attractive but ok the computer
likes it that that's good yeah and here
blackest is probably winning you can I'm
just I'm just tearing apart the center
now the the real issue really was that
white what could have refuted my play
with this which is just very strong and
I have big problems and this means that
the concept is wrong but I'm not quite
sure how to improve it I mean starting
here you can think of some things now
maybe a six earlier or avoid queen bee
six something like that so maybe maybe a
better but what is probably preserving
some some edge in any case alright
thanks for watching